vermintide - occupies a unique part of
the game space it's based on a franchise
that historically has been a little
inaccessible and real nerdy in all the
best ways but his basic moment-to-moment
gameplay is accessible to anyone with
thumbs and a compunction to smash waves
of enemies on top of that it's deep
enough to keep the truly dedicated happy
you know the ones that list min maxing
might dwarf slayer as an interest in
their dating profiles hit me up if
you're out there at the heart of it it's
also something very familiar it's very
difficult to describe vermintide without
leaning on similarities - left for dead
fundamentally they're both games about
holding off hordes of foul enemies while
frantically scrambling for safety they
use special enemies to throw wrenches
into the best-laid plans of you and your
three allies and by the end of each
session you'll be a mixture of elated
and terrified their DNA is very similar
but vermin tied to just became the
mutated rat-faced cousin of valve zombie
shooter and it's precisely that reason
that I love it so much
before anyone says yeah obviously Dave
loves it he's a GameSpot Warhammer nerd
I I can't disagree with you I am that
but I adore this game despite the rabbit
Warhammer fandom it's fun regardless of
whether you love Warhammer or not and
either way I prefer 40k anyway but while
the core of vermintide taps into the
nearly decade old left 4 dead 2 even
down to the starting camera angles and
chatter between characters the amount of
new features and wrinkles it brings the
genre outweigh the number of
inspirations it took now I put a huge
amount of time into leopard a2 but it
was always umber Steven despite the best
efforts of the game's AI director I'd
become fatigued by the sameness I craved
some more variety something different to
challenge me each time and there was
only so many times we could carry noam
chomsky 3 around I kept coming back for
that rad guitar riff a victory but over
time it started to feel a little bit
less enticing the AI director's job was
to try and keep each round feeling new
and different by placing enemies in
response to your behavior this would on
paper keep you on the edge of your seat
and punish you for your mistakes women
tied to aims to do something similar but
its director has studied valves and set
out to pick up where it left off with so
many hours in left 4 dead 2 it would get
to the point where players wouldn't know
where to expect tanks and what strategy
works best against the giant beasts but
vermintide too has gone to extra lengths
to ensure you never become comfortable
and it never becomes predictable it will
try to separate you with gas bombs or
ambush loan players with gutter honors
you could run through part of level once
and never see a single storm fiend and
then the next time a huge lumbering
Beast could pinch you in a corner and
immolate you with warp fire that truly
is nowhere safe which makes a
hard-fought victory all the more sweeter
if you explore the levels which in
itself is a challenge because the longer
you linger the more chance there is of a
hook rats snatching you away you can
find tomes and grimoires each of which
increase the value of the loot you win
at the end of a run but tomes take up a
valuable healing slot and grimoires can
massively reduce your maximum HP but as
much as the game is already challenging
you you'll want that extra struggle
because it's so much fun to earn a new
set of pistols that really finish off
your witch hunter build creating an
element of risk and reward with
in each match and tying it to new
equipment and character progression
makes repeat players feel fresh there's
so many more variables for you to think
about and for the AI director to
manipulate which also means women tied
to becomes an experience with longevity
it's obvious to say but the additional
varied classes with their own suite of
perks and abilities brings a ton of
replayability to a game - which is
important when you consider that
vermintide revolves around surviving
increasingly challenging levels
repeatedly the game taps into warhammers
deep source material to create
characters that are interesting to fans
while also keeping them accessible
enough so that anyone can identify and
enjoy them you can easily slip into your
tank rogue fighter or Ranger character
with a little experimentation while it
was fun mowing down zombies with an
assault rifle standing side by side to a
dwarf that's wielding a shield half the
size of him while a fire mage slings
balls of flame over your shoulder adds a
certain cinematic thrill to the action
and since builds change that moment of
going back to back where the teammate
never become stale in game there's
always someone different by your side
even when the person controlling them is
the same and you'll have a lot of these
moments obviously one of the biggest
changes between left of dead and
vermintide is the focus on melee combat
but it's way deeper and more nuanced
than I'd expected sure it's easy to
glance at a gameplay video and think yet
this is left-click o'clock and spamming
attacks is the order of the day but
there's much more to consider when it
comes to your character in your arsenal
and it's these elements that give you
options in the middle of a tough
skirmish have you got daggers you'll be
attacking nice and fast but you should
go for crits and your block will be
pretty weak using a hammer you'll have
big wide sweeps that are good for crowd
control but you're slow attacks might
hamper you against the big special
enemies wielding a flail you can go
around shields but make sure that it's
your job to focus shield using enemies
vermintide - makes you feel like you're
constantly on the edge of being
overwhelmed but in those moments when
everything clicks and you're pushing
back waves and waves of enemies axes
cleaving through rats fireballs and
arrows flying through the skies and
you're left on a slither of health
surrounded by your defeated foes you
feel like a goddamn hero
and that's not a feeling that is easy to
stir in a player so frequently yeah at
the end of a difficult vermintide run as
you step through that portal to victory
you breathe a sigh of heavy relief and
start thinking about venturing back in
all over again
so that's my take on vermintide - coming
from a guy who's played a heck of a lot
left 4 dead 2 it stood so many similar
emotions in me but it's also created
something so new and unique and it's
been amazing to see people enjoy it so
far especially as it's a Warhammer game
I was already invested in the fandom if
you've been enjoying vermintide - let me
know in the comments section below if
you've got a different opinion on the
argument the vermintide - picks up where
left4dead left off then be sure to shout
at me in the comment section below as
well and make sure you stick around and
I promise I will talk about a game that
isn't focused on a Warhammer universe
soon thanks for watching and I'll see
you in the next one